Shakespeare didn't sound like this,
and he didn't sound like this either,
but if you were back in 1610 and you snagged a couple of front row tickets to
the globe,
what kind of English would you hear?
I have a confession,
a tough one for a language nerd.
Here it goes.
I'm never really got into Shakespeare.
I remember the theater Geeks,
the girl with one hand raised head turned chanting lines to whom?
Exactly.
Maybe a poetry living squirrel now wasn't for me.
I was into Legos and languages,
which is how I ended up unintentionally parsing homer in Greek before I had to
face Shakespeare.
Yes.
Had to a class assignment.
I think it was the tempest.
I skimmed just enough to pass a quiz.
Then I honestly would have shelved the barred forever.
But for that one stray remark,
as the theater geeks done their best British accents,
random gadflies sneered hey,
you know what?
Shakespeare really sounded like.
He sounded like us.
Know what had I missed something about Shakespeare,
something that took linguistic detective work to solve something like his poor
spelling.
It's there in the bad quartos secretly scribbled by some bootlegger in the
audience.
It's there in the good quartos and the first folio to even on his own grave dig
and fringed look almost childish and he's stacked they and that keep us
simplified.
Dramatic letters.
Thorn.
Hmm.
This isn't his spelling.
1400 Chaucer's English was a very readable Tanga so readable.
That's 75 years later,
Mr Caxton imported a printing press to cash in on that readability.
But one day a merchant came to town and ordered eggs.
A woman said,
sorry,
a SPEC nor Frinch.
The merchant got mad.
He wasn't speaking French,
he just wanted some eggs.
Someone jumped in to help.
Oh,
he means a iron Caxton griped low what shoulder man?
In these days,
new race EEGs or Erin unleash the spelling debates.
How to spell Kenesha when it was evolving into neat.
Should [inaudible] have a C and why?
Oh,
why did Chaucer's Val's fall apart so fast by 1600 the ongoing great val shift
was turning he into a a became e and o was,
Ooh,
welcome to early modern English.
Shakespeare's tongue.
Good friend.
For Jesus Sake.
For Bay to dig the Dustin Crows that are not here air just of many rhymes that
well they aren't rhymes anymore.
Play with rhymed with dreaded are with her and own with alone.
You find critters,
raisins,
oh,
we'd find with company shold kept it's all and didn't match.
Would extra credit spelled two words that sound like society and rhyme.
With variety
you get less and pray and pray and sad,
but then the rhymes with say sweet,
we're all of these actually eat or maybe the was there.
Well,
fortunately we find ear witness accounts of a meat meat merger say was in the
process of merging with see with caution.
Rhymes may even help us recover puns like probably resins and maybe boil and
rhythm like those items.
My teacher made us drum out in class.
Those count how many syllables were in say enclosed two,
two syllables except to hear it demands three and close it.
Meter can also reveal stress.
Not housewifery but as afraid.
Okay,
you're learned.
No.
You see in sand says a noun and a verb.
It's no longer strange for you to hear,
oh,
he knew the Rez and led away and you can stomach the news that Shakespeare's
name may have been Shakespeare or schecks bear.
In 1889 Alexander Ellis added one more piece of evidence.
Modern dialects,
dialects contained traces of a time before English had a proper accent.
People who still don't merge meet with Mitt quiches that aren't witches and
dropped ours.
H List Arts and Jaron engines sounds downright Shakespearian like some dialects
still do.
He used both though and polite.
You though us though arch,
you'll have your and the third person like in Sheth was still competing with us
and we'll data crunchers deflate legends of his peerless vocabulary.
He was endlessly inventive with meaning and syntax.
Try out this word,
order voy with death and with reward.
Did threaten and encourage him not doing it on being done playful a tangle for
audiences to entire on the spot.
So what about listening to a whole play?
Linguists,
David Crystal tested that in a newly reconstructed globe,
thrown back into an era of standing heckling and oop original pronunciation.
Play goers detected suspicious traces of one particular dialect,
their own.
There's something universal about learning to pronounce.
We all come as strangers to Shakespeare's sounds.
Whether you're a theater geek who quotes hamlet by heart,
or you're me,
who I'm about to finish animating this and read it for the very first time,
I think you patrons for unlocking this and keeping me creating and to everyone
watching,
are you privy Tyree?
I'm subscribing for language.